he's a computer scientist and internet
entrepreneur he's ranked 19th on Forbes
billionaires list with an estimated net
worth of thirty three point four billion
dollars
he leads a company with over 57,000
employees in over 40 countries
he's Google co-founder Larry Page and
here is top 10 rules for success a lot
of times my shows people are not setting
goals that will be something that
somebody who becomes rich or as could do
anything you got to be excited about
working on that for 10 years so you got
to have a big enough coal that you know
you attract the best people and you
retain them and you keep them focused
and then my experience you don't go
wrong you know maybe you don't hit it
next year or maybe you fail entirely and
you discover something more exciting to
work on with the same set of people one
of the things that I've been through as
a student was some leadership training
and one of the things they taught us was
to have to not be afraid of failure now
and instead have the goal to fail a lot
quickly and then eventually you'll
succeed and I sort of took this to heart
and they'll start a slogan called
healthy disregard for the impossible and
they actually made you write down sort
of the things you would do that we're
kind of impossible but you thought you
might really accomplish and that's
really stuck with me and in everything
that I've tried to do and I think you
know it's very very close that we
wouldn't have started the company and I
think there are many of you out there in
sort of similar situations you know do
you want to take a little bit more risk
do you want to try something out and you
know even if you don't succeed we've
actually tried many things that didn't
work you know Google happens to work
pretty well but there are many things
that we did that didn't but we don't
worry about those right because we we
tried many things so I just encourage
you to take a little more risk in life
and I think if you do it often enough
they will really pay off this is how we
keep our innovation running I think
usually as companies get bigger they
find it really hard to have small
innovative projects
and we have this problem too for a while
and we said oh we really need a new
concept you know the Google ads that's a
small project that we're not quite sure
if it's going to work or not but we hope
it will and if we do enough of them some
of them will really work and turn out
such as news then we had a we had a
problem because then we had over a
hundred projects and I don't know about
all of you but I have trouble keeping a
hundred things in my head at once and we
found that if we just wrote all of them
down and ordered them and these are kind
of made up and I don't really pay
attention to them for example the the by
Iceland which from a media article we
would never do such a crazy thing but
today case we found if we just basically
wrote them all down and ordered them
that most people would actually agree
what the ordering should be and this was
kind of a surprise to me but we found
that as long as you keep the hundred
things in your head which you did by
writing them down that you could do a
pretty good job deciding what to do and
where to put your resources and so
that's basically what we've done since
means to that of years ago and I think
has really allowed us to be innovative
and still stay reasonably well organized
I talked a little bit about focusing the
company and you know I think that I want
to talk a little bit about making some
big bets and you know we always try to
concentrate on the long term what we're
doing for the long term and you know I
think that you know many of the things
we started up that are really big now
like Chrome we're seen as kind of crazy
when we launched them and so how do we
decide what to do what do you know how
do we decide what's really important to
work on well I like to call the
toothbrush test so the tooth project
asked is do you use it as often as you
use your toothbrush and for most people
I guess that's twice a day or is your
hand twice a day yeah okay most people
so I think you know we really want
things like that and I think things like
Gmail obviously I use much more than
twice a day and YouTube you know I think
that those things are amazing and I
think that
you know we look at things like YouTube
people thought oh you guys are never
going to make money without you bought
it for 1.4 billion dollars you know
you're totally crazy and we were
reasonably crazy but it was a good bet
and we've actually been doubling revenue
every year on YouTube for four years and
actually if you're doubling things it
starts to add up pretty quickly even no
matter where you start from so I think
that's a good example of the how sort of
our philosophy is that we see things
that people use a lot that they're going
to that are going to be really important
to them and we think that usually you
can make money from those things over
time you know a well-run technology
business can be monetized over time I
think a lot of companies not so much
these days but still get started because
some space is hot and honestly I don't
think that's very good reason to start a
company and in fact we see you know
hundreds or thousands of people come to
us who want to commercialize something I
want us to collaborate with their
business and we actually look at these
and I look at saw quite a few of them
and my guess is like one one a year we
are interested in so you know the trick
is to have the one that somebody's going
to be interested because it's a good
idea and not so you know be one of the
thousands that come through all the time
and I think you know if you're the one
good good deal or you have a good idea
you really understand the area you're in
you know the funding environment doesn't
matter it doesn't matter whether it's a
hot area you know I guarantee you be
able to get people interested in helping
you out and I think for all of you there
are many areas where there's leverage
available in the world where you know
one or two people a good idea a lot of
hard work can really make a difference
there's many many things like that and
it's good not to forget that but it's
good to look for those things googles
mission is to organize the world's
information and make it universally
accessible and useful and one of the
things that surprised me that's a very
broad mission it's a lot of work we're
not going to achieve it anytime soon
right it's almost an impossible task but
it's an exciting task and one that
you can get other people excited about
and they can help you and one of the
things that surprised me is sometimes
easier to do something that's harder
because other people get excited about
it and you can get much more resource
you can get tremendous resources to
solve a hard problem or as you might
only get minor resources to solve a
small problem
you know anything you can imagine
probably is doable right you just have
to imagine it and work on it and things
that we thought were almost impossible
so we we were interested in machine
translation there are services on the
web we had licensed one that which could
translate between different languages
and obviously for search you know if you
can't if the information is not in your
language we can't find it for you and
most information is not in your language
right
this is sort of a by definition and so
we thought well be great if we could
provide search results from any language
for any query and so we're really
focused on that problem and we focused
on it and we developed Google Translate
and we we found some machine learning
researchers and we said do you think you
can translate you know between any
languages and do it better than an
average human translator and they said
they laughed at us he said no we can't
possibly do that but actually we're
willing to try and you know six years
later we can translate between 64
languages and it's amazing actually
we're better many languages were better
than an average human translating I mean
do it instantly and for free and between
those 64 languages we can translate
between any two of the languages so we
have something like 4,000 languages we
can translate between and so I'm just
trying to give you I guess I'm
tremendously optimistic that whatever
things we try to challenge whatever
challenges we try to take on we can
solve with a little bit of concerted
effort and some good technology and I
think that's a really exciting place to
be in the world so I think we want more
people work on it we want to have more
ambitious goals and I think with that we
could easily double kind of human
progress and the rate
which were developing so I'm gonna
switch gears and talk really briefly
about entrepreneurship so I'll try to
give you some of the things I think are
really important that other people won't
tell you or won't stress as much and one
of those is really just don't settle
it's very very very important if you're
starting company to have the right
people involved I can't stress that
enough I've been you know enormous ly
happy with people we've had involved at
Google with my co-founder and with Eric
and we took a long time to find these
people actually I've been working with
Sergey for a really long time but Eric
took us over your tire Eric and just
generally having great people involved
that you really like and that are
compatible with you and all those things
is tremendously important and you're
never going to question the equity you
gave up or any of the other things so I
can't stress that enough
the other thing I think we really
benefited from as being real experts we
worked on Google for many years at
Stanford before we started the company
and that was a pretty nice position to
be and we understood sort of all aspects
of search we talked to all the search
companies for many years we really
really knew a lot about was going on and
you can do that pretty cheaply right
it's just your labor right you can
invest a year or two or three years and
really learn something very very well
before you start having hundreds of
people you know working on the problem
recently I reorganized a bit to focus on
product areas and I think you know in
any company as it grows you know if the
company is not static which shouldn't be
you know has it grows and it changes you
know you need to reorganize it and just
question is you know are you keeping
ahead of that and looking at the our
business is pretty complicated we have
all these different products we have
advertising we have search we have
chrome we have Android we have YouTube
and so on and those things are actually
relatively different have different
different things going on so I think you
know I kind of moved that up a level in
the company and made sure that we were
super focused in each of those areas on
what our user experience was and I think
that's that's helped just generally as
you switch to company as we got more
offices you know as we got time zone
differences we had to change how we did
our meetings change how we do our
employee communications and so on so I
just think you know anti-technology
business is growing rapidly just need to
make sure you're changing everything you
know you're being responsive to that
change and changing everything you know
every year or else you're just not
keeping up with it I want to talk about
dreams for a second
and in my case literally a dream when I
was in college I was sure that I've been
admitted by a clerical error
Broly a computer error and because of
that I had an irrational fear I'd be
sent home on the bus and Sergey Sierra
knows this is true but it turns out
because of that anxiety I woke up
literally with a dream it was kind of a
strange dream it went like I think I
could download the entire web on to some
old computers that were lying around and
that would probably seem pretty crazy to
most people but I stayed up a couple
hours in the middle of the night doing
some math and it seemed actually pretty
plausible while assuming he actually
didn't keep any of the webpages you only
kept the links and then sort of figured
outs
given all that data I thought I would
take a couple weeks and I told my
advisor that and he just sort of laughed
to me and of course took a year or two
but at the end of that we had a way to
rank web pages and no thoughts to search
at all and eventually search entered the
picture and you know the rest
and that became Google
so make your own gentleman follow their
dreams thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because sick
Nick 95 asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur do you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what you've Larry
page's top 10 rules meant the most to
you is going to have the biggest impact
on you leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon